hot damn youtubers it's Charlie this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 5 video
not a whole lot happened in this episode
despite the fact that there were some
big reveals I mean it wasn't a big
action episode they're kind of holding
off for like more big super PAC stuff so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet here we go
Andrew quick reminder new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's a $20 Amazon
gift card let's start with the biggest
hot damn Mackey is pregnant so now Glen
has a reason to come back I think he's
definitely still alive and then there'll
be that moment in the back half where
it's like I have a son
I have a son oh my god I have to get
back so everybody that thinks that we're
gonna get this kind of moment like this
moment of realization when the light
bulb goes on Glen finds out that he has
his son and he just like freaks out
trying to get back to Maggie tell me
there's something more Rick well in
about nine months give or take a couple
weeks something more is gonna be
crawling out from between Maggie's legs
and it might be named Aaron Aaron or air
in both good names for boys and girls on
the number four hot damn Jessie she
serves as this big call to action for
most of the other regular SafeZone
people people that aren't survivors that
are just like kind of waking up to the
reality of what life is right now we
have to fight or we die and it actually
like it becomes this big call to action
for Denise's character too they kind of
throw into that moment where she's like
oh okay I can save this guy you really
have to credit Tara for a little bit of
that too it's like like Denise just
needs a big confidence boost and Tara's
there to provide it
I don't know necessarily that they're
gonna have some sort of lesbian
relationship I think they're just gonna
have a really deep friendship I think at
this point we shouldn't read too much
into that kiss until we see them do
something more until it gets into Glenn
Maggie territory I wouldn't call them in
an official relationship but you can
totally [ __ ] them I'm a huge fan of
Merritt Wever
and the funny thing about Tara's
character is that a lot of masterson the
actors that plays Tara is pregnant in
real life so they keep they keep hiding
her stomach behind things like that's
why she sat down on that chair that way
but right now like as of this Sunday
when I posting this video she's already
had the baby but they're shooting the
back half of the episodes so Tara
on-screen is still gonna seem pregnant
for like at least the next several
episodes lauren cohan on the other hand
is gonna be pregnant on the show but not
pregnant in real life it just is just
one of the funny things that happens
with casts that are really
on shows that go on for a long time
there's always gonna be a ton of babies
born in real life and you're probably a
couple babies born on the show like
written into the story but as far as I
know lauren cohan isn't actually having
a baby in real life like it's just it's
just something they wrote as part of
this narrative on the number three
though mini porchdick
versus mini rick this is actually a
relatively positive art cut I know it
seems like they were having a fight but
mini porchdick here Jesse's son really
does want to help Carl like he doesn't
want him to go out there he just thinks
it's too dangerous and eated can
probably take care of herself I think
that he does believe she can take care
of herself but he's accepted the fact
that it's just too dangerous for them to
go out so he doesn't want Carl to throw
his life away and even better than that
he goes to talk to Rick just just to let
him know what's going on with Carl like
all he's over there with Judith he
didn't actually go over the wall so he's
safe but could you teach me how to shoot
that's huge like he tells Rick yeah you
were right when you got really pissed at
me in Episode one when I was wandering
around outside thanks for being hard on
me I understand what you're trying to do
so he's not asking Rick to adopt him or
anything he's just accepting what
happened he's like I'm moving forward I
understand it was necessary so they're
just paving away for something happy to
come out of that storyline between
Jesse's family and Rick's family but
speaking of messed up families out of my
number two WTF Deanna and Spencer so
this is so messed up Deanna is just
completely off the reservation and
Spencer has this really heartfelt speech
where he inspires everyone to just put
the food back please let's not make
things go to [ __ ] faster than they need
to she comes out of her funk she starts
planning for a way to defend the safe
zone it's really positive but then she
catches him being a complete douchebag
well I figure if only one person stolen
no one saw it wouldn't be a big deal I
feel like they're setting Spencer up to
do something terrible he's gonna have
some huge dirt and he's gonna wind up
dead that's what I feel that cracker
sleeve moment was at the end like Rosita
tries to comfort him and say hey
whatever you're doing just keep doing it
it's totally working and then he pulls
the crackers sleepout I feel like that
was meant to be ominous and then finally
under my number one WTF moment Deniz
bangs on the fence is an act of defiance
but we also see that the walls are
bleeding a little bit
meaning that it's not invincible if the
walls will come down at a certain point
they they won't hold forever and they'll
just have to wait to find out what
happened to Abraham Glen Daryl I think
next week's episode is gonna address
what's going on with them and I do think
the show is doing hilltop
so they might start running into some
new characters because we're getting
really close to the midseason finale
there has to be some big conflict and
I'm actually I'm curious to see how long
they stretch out this super-pac
storyline like if this goes all the way
to the mid-season finale because as of
right now you have the crazy wolf that
Morgan is keeping locked up he's gonna
get out at some point that that'll
probably be part of the mid-season
finale WTF or something leading up into
it you have half the super PAC that is
slowly making the walls bleed all over
the place and then you have everybody
inside that's like slowly breaking down
mentally that was actually a really good
quote that Rick had early in the episode
the biggest danger isn't so much the
wall coming down the wall is strong it's
everyone inside breaking down mentally
so there are a couple of shining rays of
hope we have Glenn to Maggie's child
we have Taryn Denise and then we have
Rick and Jesse and Oh Carol wasn't in
this episode but we did see a plate of
cookies even though it's it's not the
same thing when they're not being used
as a threat cookies will never be the
same after the second half of season 5
so here's my big question for you guys
out of the other big people that they
mentioned in the episode that are stuck
out there Daryl Sasha and Abraham do you
think that all of them will make it back
I feel like Darrow is pretty safe
Abraham could totally go like the show
could lose him and I feel like it
wouldn't completely break things Sasha
is kind of on a comic book
Andria Arc so I feel like they're trying
to build that character up so I don't
think that Sasha is gonna die so really
if I had to pick someone that they could
killed this season that like a big
member of the group it would be Abraham
because he is starting to feel kind of
overpowered and it looks like he kind of
wants to die a little bit like he's got
that crazy energy like when he was
talking to Sasha you doing this cuz you
want to die you guys can let me know if
you agree though like do you think that
Abraham is gonna die during season 6 or
you think he'll make it to season 7 I
just feel of all the group members you
could lose you know without the
integrity of the group completely being
destroyed
Abraham's one of those people so if the
show needs another WTF in the back half
abraham would be a good sacrifice to
make and I'll totally offer my
condolences to all the reshow and
shippers out there and I know everyone
wants to see Rick with Michonne just
because he's with Jesse now doesn't mean
that it won't ever happen the TV show is
actually expanded Jesse's part
incredibly from the comic her part in
the comic book is way smaller but I will
say congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner seal of approval
what an awesome avatar you win a $20
Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so and get
your contact info what's gonna happen
next is I still have a game of Thrones
video to do there's some new Star Wars
footage that I kind of want to do a
video for hopefully I'll get that all
out and still had time to do Gotham like
I don't want to have to delay videos
like I did last week so just stay tuned
on Twitter and Facebook
I'll post updates throughout the day
tomorrow while you guys wait for all
that stuff to post you can click here
for last week's episode of The Walking
Dead and you can click here for the
flash trail that I just posted all kinds
of zooms stuff happening thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow